- On commence-tu par Monk?
- All right.
- OK!
- Il est 20 h 30. Dehors,
la température ressentie
de la Maison Benoit Labre
sillonnent les rues
du Sud-Ouest...
à la recherche de personnes
en situation d'iuation d'iuatio.
- Café.tes
entrent dans le métro Monk,
cherchent des visages connus.
- On vparce que les policiers s.
- Valérie les rejoint pour voir
si elle peut porter assistance.
- Ça se passe quand même bien
- Elles laissent donc
les policiers inour
se rendre sur le quai du métro.
- Elle réveille une veille dame,
ement pas une habituée
de la rue.
- Sais-tu où est-ce qu'ost-ce q,
nous autres, à St-Henri?
- Non.
si elle veut aller
ne halte chaleur.
Elle refuse; elle ne se sent pas
en sécurité dans ces endromain
à la Maison Benoit Labre.
- Ah, bien, je suis contente.
Ça, ça fait mon affaire, ça,
pour pet me et me et me et me e.
- L'équipe se rend à l'édicule
pour voir Creg.
- Est-ce que tu as une place
- J'ai un place, mais pas chaud,
pas d'électricit
- Pour se réchauffer, il flâne.
C'est pourquoi la Maison Benoit
de Montréal d'ouvrir
ns édiculens édiculens édiculeno
par temps froid.
Des navettes comme celle-ci
ou celle-là, te moins
d'une dizaine à Montréal gérées
par différents organismes.
Mission Old Brewery
rrive à l'offrir
généralement de 15 h à 23 h,
pour la petite navette,
que ce soit doublé.
- La Ville de Montréal
offre plus de 1900 places
cette année : un record.
anque de lits, c'est
davantage dû à un manque
de main-d'oeuvre,du Centre-Sud.
- J'ai vu passer les chiffres
de 1500-1800. Ça inclut
les places qui sont dédiées
à ldu stade, oui, c'est 320 pla,
350 places, mais c'est
uniquement pour les personnes
qui ont la COVID.
- Fait que là, on a toutes
C'est mis à
jour. Fait que les gens disent :
"Oui, je veux une placeeux
et chanceuses, on trouveune pla,
mais ça arrive pas souvent.
- De moins en mo moins en moinse
dehors par froid glacial.
- Le problèmebergementsbergemen,
ça ne date pas d'hier.
Il n'y a pas assez de lits
à Montréal malgré ce que
se tue à dire dans les médias,
il n'y en a pas assez de p
- Samedi soir, en une heure,
neuf personnes hors refuge.
- On devrait en
trois navettes.
(rires)
Comeau, Radio-Canada, Mont